[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
this is a cosmic queries edition in the
coronaverse
as we continue to have our guests join
us from wherever they are
in the universe uh but but first the way
i got my co-host chuck chuck nice
hey how are you doing chuck what's
happening i'm actually all right
breakfast neil
i'm having okay they're very nice
there's more than i cared to know about
you this morning
that's fine i know you don't care about
my my nutrition
you're tweeting at chuck nice comic
always good to follow you there
and so today's cosmic queries it's on a
topic we have yet to
really jump into hahaha
we're talking about volcanoes ah i see
what you did there
you see what i did there wasn't that
clever of me
okay no none of us have any such
expertise
so we coned earth to find
and there are a few of them out there a
few i think they're called
volcanologists
um and we found one who works with the
smithsonian institution
uh in washington dc and a welcome janine
[ __ ] kip kripner thank you very much for
having me here um first of all please
don't go jumping into volcanoes
i do not recommend
that is an important question clearly
for 2020 we have not been appraising the
gods
[Laughter]
so you're a volcanologist which has to
also mean that you're
fundamentally a geologist is that
correct there are different types of
volcanologists so
gas physics but i guess i am a geology
based volcanologist
so i look at a lot of rocks a lot of
rocks and the the smithsonian
global vulcanism program like what is
that
so it's this really neat program where
we're basically recording and keeping
track of
the world's volcanic eruptions i'm glad
somebody's doing that that's right good
good okay thanks for letting us in on
this fact that somebody's taking care of
business
okay yeah i know there are um volcano
observatories around the world they do
the day-to-day monitoring
um and making sure we're trying to make
sure the communities are safe but we
collate all of that data
so that we have this wealth of knowledge
about volcanoes so we can look back and
study them and look for any patterns or
have a better understanding of what
volcanoes do
so how many volcanoes are being actively
sort of monitored at this moment
oh actively monitored i don't know but
do you guys know
how many are actively erupting today no
no no
no what's your guess uh i'm i'm gonna
say
too many that's my guess that's where
i'm
too many many volcanoes
i'd say 150. 44 ongoing eruptions
but there are over 1400 volcanoes that
we consider to be potentially active
so that means they've erupted within the
last 10 000 years so in the holocene
um and that's that's a baby for a
volcano that's not so the whole
scene is is that what we're now calling
our our time the time of civilization
uh i've been on the scene the fringe of
the debate on that
um but hollistein is the last 10 to 12
000 so that's that's when humans have
had agriculture
and when we've been sort of doing our
thing creating civilization
right well we base it um we use
that age because in the northern
hemisphere that's when a lot of the ice
sheets came down and actually removed a
lot of
the recent before that um records of
volcanic activity so
from 10 to 12 thousand thousand years
onwards we have a much better record of
what volcanoes have actually done
oh i see so the ice age wiped your slate
clean
a little bit oh okay interesting
so now where where do you stand on the
anthropocene
i'm just curious i'm just curious you're
trying to pick a fight
that's why i asked the question chuck
step away from the microphone
step away
as this spokesperson today they would
ask us to stop polluting the planet but
they don't care about that
okay that's a whole other show chuck
talking about yeah the anthropocene
yeah yeah so so with with volcanoes so i
i can't with the number 150 because i i
think there's active ones and then
there's
sure but then they're ones that like
could blow at any moment
that was that closer to what my number
would be maybe um
so the ones that could start an eruption
any time would be
that 1400 plus
um so while they might not be showing
any signs of erupting today or tomorrow
even next year
that can change very quickly so there
are four we have to prioritize
somehow which volcanoes we're going to
put our resources and our monitoring
into so that's a good start is looking
at okay which ones have erupted recently
which ones have young magmatic systems
underneath them that might
start anytime soon so magmatic means
just
molten rock magmatic that's the like the
verb
or another the adjective yeah it's like
if you have a lava lamp above the
surface it's a lava lamp if you put it
below the surface it's a magma lamp
so magma below lava
oh interesting so so magma that's hit
the surface it has a new name even
though it's the same stuff
yeah i mean it does change because now
it's atmospheric pressure so it starts
to crystallize and cool down
and it releases a lot more gas very
quickly so there are changes but it's
the same
stuff okay i i've never thought about
that
okay so you wouldn't speak
you wouldn't speak of magma rivers
flowing down a volcano those are lava
rivers
that moments ago were magma coming up
out of the caldera
yes okay and do you do you sell magma
hats
because i've been trying to get time
i just want one of those magma hats i
love them so much
um i might have to make them black like
the rock once it's cooled down instead
of
red you had me at black janine
and i and i wanted to make fun of the
fact that you had two different words
but in my
world uh we have three different words
for the same
thing right so there's uh
so there's an asteroid moving through
space
if it's visible as it descends through
the atmosphere then it's a meteor
and then after it hits the ground and
you pick it up it's a meteorite
yeah same damn thing and it's all the
same thing same damn thing yeah you can
actually be confused
well yeah they're very complicated these
astrophysicists
so let's start with questions this must
have been a very fertile topic
because who doesn't think about
volcanoes in our lives without a doubt
yeah every day so you know what we
normally do we go out to our
uh various incarnations on the internet
and we ask people to send in their
inquiries
uh we always start with the patreon
patron because uh they give us money
and uh quite frankly we just we love
that transaction it's a lovely channel
chuck we need a more a less crass way to
communicate this information that's
that's why i love it so much
anyway okay here we go so let's start
with christopher
zappell on patreon and he asked
uh are there any new developments with
the super
volcano under yellowstone and i will add
to christopher's question
uh as an addendum what is the super
volcano under yellowstone so janine
what's up
with a super volcano i should have
placed a bit that this would be the
first
question i knew it was coming so super
volcano is actually what i don't like
it's a word that means a volcano that
can produce these
largest style of eruptions what we call
we have a vei
or a volcano explosivity index which
goes from smaller eruptions to the
biggest of the big so this has been
coined a super eruption
the biggest style of eruption and a
super volcano is a volcano that
can produce a super eruption yellowstone
has produced
two of these and its entire history so
while it may never do one again
um and at the moment there's no signs
that it even has enough magma to do that
anytime
soon it's just a word that says that
it's capable
because it has in the past of producing
these very large eruptions
as far as new developments go people are
always trying to learn more about this
volcano basically getting more
understanding of the subsurface of the
geothermal system which is not really
related
to the subsurface and the yellow stone
volcano observatory which is part usgs
part university is part of their
organization so usgs
united states geological survey yes usgs
yeah but it's not just them it's a group
of organizations that are monitoring
this volcano and constantly looking at
um the geology to understand what style
of eruptions have happened before and
therefore
what it might do in the future but so
how how
when when was the last eruption however
um the last eruption i think yellowstone
the last eruption was about 70 000 years
ago and that was just a lava flow
um in fact the last 50 eruptions
yellowstone most of them have just been
lava flows
in other words it's just the potential
for
the eruption it's i mean it's not that's
it just it could i mean that's like and
it has
it has and therefore it could or maybe
janine
just just admit it say we have no idea
yeah
because i couldn't say it that's not a
real thing it's just not a really good
like descriptor because it's like me
saying i'm a super dad
i never met my kids i don't play child
support but i couldn't
most of the eruptions are much much
smaller but it's become this
it's like the adult version of the
monster under the beard at this point
all right
okay let's move on let's next question
let's go to christopher fowler
dr tyson and dr krippner in regards to
volcanic emissions
and climate change does volcanic
activity
release more greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere
than human activity now you know climate
obfuscators
often cite volcanic activity
as one of the main contributors to
greenhouse gases on earth
so so janine where do volcanoes fit in
the equation
in the in the greenhouse equation so
looking at carbon dioxide alone which as
we know
is a very large culprit humans were
released through fossil fuels and our
activities 40 to 100 times more
than all volcanoes so under the ocean
and on land there's a huge program
and the deep carbon observatory that's
been actually looking into this
and no we are releasing so much more
than volcanoes
so volcanoes are not the problem they
shouldn't even be part of the
conversation because they're going to do
what they're going to do anyway right
yeah they are they helped us get our
atmosphere in the beginning and they're
a very important part of the carbon
natural carbon cycle
and our atmosphere and all these
nutrients but as far as what we're
seeing now with climate change or um
global warming or whatever you want to
call it they are not the culprit
we are let me invert the question so if
you could find a way
to tap a volcano releasing some of the
gas pressures so that it never blows
and maybe use the energy from that
tapping process to drive the
power needs of a city that might
otherwise be leveled
under under a lava slide
you're saying that's not good for the
greater balance of the earth's
ecosystem because earth needs some rate
of volcanoes to sustain
its balance is that is that a true
statement oh yeah i think so i mean
not that we can't we can't stop
eruptions that's something we cannot do
we are so tiny
on the scale of these enormous enormous
systems
but they're a hugely important part of
life on this planet
um just for like for life for uh soils
for the atmosphere for nutrients
so no we shouldn't be stopping them
that's just what our planet does that is
part of us living here
when it happens when people are involved
of course that's heartbreaking and
devastating
but it is something that we have to live
with i just love the fact that neil
degrasse tyson turned into a bond
villain just then
it's just kill the volcano
that's very cool yeah be careful what
you wish for right if you get rid of all
the volcanoes something else go
happens down the line 2020 please stop
saying stuff like that
all right all right chuck one more
question before we go to break
okay all right um
i love this this is karen netherland
from facebook
and uh karen says hi this question is
from jackson who is six years old
jackson would like to know why do
volcanoes explode
oh ooh that's a really good question
yeah
we actually don't have time to get to
jackson's question right now
but when we return we will find out why
volcanoes blow in the first place on
star talk
star talk we're back cosmic queries the
volcano edition of cosmic queries i got
chuck nice and as always chad
yes sir yes sir and we have our
volcano expert they do exist in this
world
janine krippner janine works for
smithsonian
and if you uh heard our first segment
you caught a little bit of an accent
in her and you hail from originally
where janine
new zealand and when i'm in new zealand
my accent is much stronger i promise
so thanks for tamping it down for us so
we can understand your english
i visited new zealand a couple years ago
it's a beautiful place and i would
return in a heartbeat
and of course i visited hobbiton
yeah and we the whole family went and my
son didn't he wanted to move there
he just wanted to live in hobbiton i
don't blame him that's actually just
sort of up the road from where i live
it's a beautiful place
very cool very cool so chuck we left off
with a question from a six-year-old kid
named jackson and what was that question
right
and jackson wanted to know why do
volcanoes
explode back to basics janine what do
you have for us
that's a really great question so once
we get magma high enough
down way deep deep down below it's right
magma is rising towards the surface
because it's less
dense than the rock around it so if you
pour oil into water
the oil rises because it's less dense
same thing
once you get it closer to the surface
that magma has a lot of gas in it very
very gassy stuff a whole lot of
different kinds of gas
chuck is gassy all the time i've known
i i hope you're okay with that well i
eat up
it's because i eat a lot of vegetables
that's all
good it's healthy i'm just glad we're on
zoom right now and not
well thanks for playing along there to
me
okay go on so volcanoes can be just as
dangerous
if not more um once you get them closer
to the surface there's less pressure
because there's less rock
on top of the magma everything's being
pulled down because of gravity
so that pressure is reducing so if you
think of a bottle of soda
when you get it straight out of the
store you can't see the gas you know
there's gas in it
but that gas is under pressure it's
inside the liquid it's in solution
once you take the cap off that's
releasing the pressure and that gas can
start to come out
if you shake it up and take the cap off
that's essentially what an explosive
volcanic eruption is you have this gas
coming out
so quickly that it's violently ripping
apart the fluid or in this case the
magma or the rock
so that's why it's not just a single pop
it's not just a single amount of
pressure trying to pop a lid
it's once that does pop all these gases
now want to continue coming out
yeah yeah it can be a bit of what we
think can happen is it can be a wave
that goes down that conduit of the magma
once you have a more of an open system
so it's already made its way to the
surface you can have more discrete
eruptions or explosions we call those
volcanion
or if you have runnier magma you can get
strombolian eruptions
but yeah if you have the magma coming up
hasn't erupted yet it's essentially like
shaking up a bottle of coke and taking
the lid off so you've classified
types of eruptions yes
so volcanian is where you have these
volcanic ash plumes and volcanic ash is
not smoke
it is pulverized volcanic rock and gases
so that's when you have an ash plume
that comes out and then it detaches
eventually
and then you range up to your very large
eruptions which we call plenion which is
from the vesuvius 79ed eruption
but named after pliny the altar who was
there
um and scaling it back to the other end
when we have runny of magmas we have
strombolian eruptions we have hawaiian
eruptions which is what we saw in hawaii
when that was still erupting i was going
to guess that
i was going to guess that oh good good
game the hawaiian eruptions yeah
but we do have plenty of other other
types of options too but those are the
main ones
okay all right cool so we tell jackson
it's like open up the bottle
bottle of soda outside please outside
after you shake it
that's popular
but before we get to our next question
um janine when i visited new zealand not
too long ago just a couple of years ago
i visited
christ church and they were still
recovering
from a major earthquake that had
occurred there
and i'm just wondering does proximity to
geologic activity
enhance people's interest to want to
study it
well i always loved volcanoes um i'm
pretty sure i was born that way i don't
remember when i started
but i'm the only person that i know from
my hometown who's a volcanologist
so while i'm sure it does in some ways
we have an extremely active geologic
country in new zealand we're actually on
a major plate boundary but the plate
boundary changes it's a subduction zone
in the north island and there's more of
a sort of it's moving it's a mountain
building zone
in the south island and then there's a
weird transition zone in the middle and
then in the north island we're also
rifting apart so it's a very complicated
region we have
um the potential for a lot of different
corruption centers
as well as earthquakes and tsunamis and
landslides and
they're all related i mean the moving
plates the existence of volcanoes
tsunamis they all it's all a family of
earth getting pissed off oh yeah big
heavy family
now if you were if you wanted to be a
volcanologist from very early on
you still have your eyebrows so
it seems to me you would lose those
every time you leaned into a volcano to
look in
these are painted on
i've only nearly lost uh eyebrows or
or you know i'm here once um but no i
haven't leaned over a crater
looking into lava yet so i'll let you
know the eyebrow status after that
gotcha okay
i want a full report i'll let you know
all right chuck what else do you have
yeah that's pretty good actually that
kind of um it's a perfect segue
into um the jezreel addicts
from instagram his question or her
question not sure
uh says hey neil big fan here and hey
janine everybody seems to be asking
about the volcanoes themselves
uh but i'm more interested in the
equipment
what ways are there to analyze volcanoes
and how far can we reach
into a volcano thanks love
love star talk and i'll just say thank
you to his last statement
because it was a compliment but i don't
need to actually
say it but
withholding compliments from you yes i'm
recording compliments from myself
you know okay yeah you're tough too yes
so janine are you in full moon suit when
you go
you know go into calderas what what's
what's your standard equipment
so going into cold air is so this i
should probably say the difference
between a crater
and a cold air so going into a crater
which i've done
it did not have lava in it most of them
don't have lava in it
um where this is a caldera uh you
mentioned you've been to yellowstone so
most all of that area within the park is
the cold air it's just so big you can't
see it
um but if you are sampling lava um you
can have that
space suit looking thing which is
basically to protect you from the heat
if you have to be there long enough but
if you run up grab a sample of lava run
away again
there was some great footage of people
doing that with their 2018 kilowatt
eruption
you don't need that so you just need to
be quick um our technology
i noticed that i visited vesuvius in
italy
and that thing i don't know when it last
erupted if not
pompeii but uh i didn't see any lava but
it was hot
it was it was hot i went down there to
get a closer picture i said i can't get
any closer and nothing was glowing
nothing was flowing so i felt like the
really inadequate stuff like i would
never be a volcanologist
no probably not you're not you're not
tough enough sorry
um i have been in a lava tube that was
so hot my eyeballs were drying out
that's
the hottest i've been um near and that
was two-year-old lava so it was mostly
cool and solidified at that point
but no they can get very dangerously hot
um
so floor is lava not a good game
so you do have a special equipment do
you uh do you have like
um do you stuff to repel down the side
of the wall
that sort of stuff too like mountain
climbing things yeah depending on
the type of field work you're doing so
there's a huge range in field work
whether you're collecting rock samples
whether you're collecting gas whether
you're
mapping um everything that's around
there whether you're looking at
temperature with your
there are so many different things to do
on a volcano and each one of them is
their own specialty
so it seems to me everything you just
said can be done with drones and robots
no no you cannot replace us with robots
you got to qualify that i mean that's
that's like me saying
um no a robot cannot tell jokes you know
like
you don't want the robot right i don't
want the robot to tell jokes but robots
can't tell jokes so
why why could you not why could you not
replace you with the robot but i got one
uh what college did the robot go to what
college did the world go to solid state
university
that supposed to be geology jerk joke
a bad one
so there are a lot of things that we
need to see in the field for ourselves
so when we're going out there
we're basically looking at everything
around us to try and understand what
this volcano has done before
so if you have a drone and it takes even
high resolution photographs or if
even if it gets samples which would be
very time consuming
we do use drones when it's dangerous
there are absolutely good uses for
drones
but there's so much more that we can do
as humans with all of the experience
that we have
knowing what to look at when you have
this huge area even when a crater
craters are really really big
you know you said you looked into
vesuvius that's you know they get much
much bigger than that and we are tiny if
you look at photos of people on craters
so there are more um there's much more
analytical
thinking that we can do with our
experience instead of sitting in a drone
saying look at that go look at that get
that sample
and things like collecting gas you need
to get it at the vent
in a lot of cases and you can get
samples using drones higher up but by
then you have the gases are diffusing
and
so drones are absolutely useful but it's
still very important that we get in the
field as well
chuck sounds to me like janine wants to
keep her job
[Laughter]
you're welcome to come and tell jerks
[Laughter]
sounds good sounds good all right um
let us move on to
uh i just like the name this is
a do russell okay and
do russell says from instagram
can a mountain ever form
into a volcano
well a lot of volcanoes are mountains
right
um and if you have a mountain area
that is a volcano you can grow new cones
which some people might call a new
volcano
if you're looking at mountain building
ranges often those are made of things
like older granite or the areas that
aren't really volcanically active
that might be more difficult to get a
volcano to form there because the bag
may
still make its way through the
subsurface and everything's under
pressure down there so it's going to
find the easiest way
to the surface so yes it absolutely
could
um it really depends on the easiest way
that the magnet can get to the surface
in that area
so i mean the magnet is opportunistic is
what you're saying yeah yes i mean it's
already come all this way like hundred
tens to hundreds of kilometers towards
the surface right
yeah so pretty hard working but when it
gets to that point it's like i can't do
no more i just i just
can't so i got you you know if you look
at all the granite in the world that's
failed eruptions technically that's
granite is magma reservoirs that froze
that stopped
that didn't erupt and slowly
crystallized below the surface
so if you look at granitic mountain
chain ranges all of that is
a magma that never managed to make its
streams as an eruption
isn't mount rushmore grant what's mount
rushmore made of
i don't actually know her sorry
i think mount rushmore is made of
american exceptionalism
[Laughter]
lost dreams all right let's get one more
before the break
okay here we go this is um this is
diego herrera from instagram he says
greetings from colombia
uh how does the temperature see what he
says that's what he says
he said it's just like that too that's
how he said he said greetings from
colombia
anyway he says how does the temperature
distribution of flowing lava change as
it comes
out of the erupting volcano specifically
how long does it take
for the lava to solidify
so jeannie i've always wondered that
because you see the lava come out it
looks like it's hardening
in situ right for the part that's but
then it breaks and keeps going
so uh what what's going on there as this
thing is flowing
but hardening at the same time yeah so
that's a really good question um so
first of all starting out in celsius
because again sorry from new zealand
um magma or lava at the very beginning
coming out the more sticky
more explosive style of lavas we call
rhyolites those are around
800 degrees ish and then we go all the
way through 800 degrees celsius
celsius just like a million degrees
fahrenheit basically
i got to take a quick break we'll come
back to learn
more about the temperature of the lava
that comes out of volcanoes when star
talk returns
star talk we're back cosmic queries the
volcano edition so we're learning about
what happens to
lava magma becoming lava is it freezing
is it flowing
what's it doing and tell me that
temperature that it is
temperature takes to liquify rock what
temperature is that so it depends on the
rock it depends on the composition of
the rock your lower temperature
compositions like rhyolite around 800
degrees ish it will take a few hundred
when you we're looking at our basaltic
lavas like a kilauea 1000 to 1200
degrees celsius so extremely hot
so when you have those lava flows or um
across the entire range all of it can
form lava flows when you come up when it
comes out of the surface as
the crust is cooling very very quickly
that's when it turns to black or grey of
some kind very quickly
if you have a really thin lava flow it
will cool a lot um
faster it can still take i don't know i
don't actually know i'm going to guess
days to weeks if it's a thinner lava
flow of a few
meters and you can get lava flows that
are tens of meters and those can take
months to years
wow and so it really depends on how much
lava you have the thickness of the lava
and how much of it is coming out but it
can take a very very long time
it's amazing wow well so this is cool
then
uh uh because kf k uh fudge uh
asked this it's perfect tie-in if
lava moves so slowly why is it so
destructive
i mean you know i guess you know get out
of the way
is really not not the way to hang out in
the cartoon
and i never understood the cartoons
where there's a ball rolling down the
hill and they're just running
away from the ball rather than just
stepping to the side
never understood that right that's a
very good hazard's advice
away from the hill but you might is that
because of these temperatures is that
really the big i mean aside from the
fact that you basically have slow-moving
rock that's going to
consume whatever's in its path but is it
the temperature
primarily that makes it so destructive
and so dangerous
some of it is pretty quick we saw that
with the fissure eights um kilauea 2018
event that was very rapidly moving lava
but even with the very small slow moving
ones you can usually out walk
um lava but it will bulldoze everything
in its path so if you have a town in the
way
it's going to go through everything but
with the fast-moving lavas
it can destroy everything and create can
create fires it can have a lot of very
dangerous gases coming off it and it's
also extremely hot so there's a there
are a lot of hazards that
are around lava flows tell me about
pyroclastic flow oh goody
yeah i will so when you're talking about
pyroclastic flows lava flows are very
slow
pyroclastic flows are essentially these
exploding rapid avalanches of
solid rock and very hot gas that race
down the volcano or away from the bin
very high speed you cannot outrun them
and they will destroy everything in
their path so they are like the
nightmares
of volcanoes these things
so is that like in the movies when you
see the big cloud
that goes down the side of the volcano
first that's the pyroclastic flow
yes like dante's peak they actually did
a really good pyroclastic flow in
dante's peak
um so they're incredibly dangerous so
that'll kill you too even though it's
not lava
it's it's very hot and that'll kill you
too many ways would you say very
volcano when you say very hot what's the
temperature we're talking about am i
going to get like burned alive i mean
how exactly am i going to die am i going
to be
covered and encased in an ash am i going
to burn up and all my flesh is going to
peel off or
chuck
[Laughter]
janine how will chuck die yeah and i'm
not talking about anybody else janine
i'm just talking about me
um you can we can have a longer
conversation about this later if you'd
like but
specifically with pyroclastic flows the
temperature is extremely dangerous
um so if you do survive that you're
looking at intense third degree burns
over much of your body especially
anything that's exposed
and you're looking at lung damage
especially if you're not wearing any
kind of
proper gas mask so the damage to the
lungs and the esophagus can be
very dangerous as well that can kill you
um and you also have a lot of rocks
unless you have a very gassy gas rich
low rock content pyroclastic flow which
we call a surge
if you have a very um rocky kind of
pipelines that flow with huge amount of
solid rocks they can be quite big too
these rocks can be the size of a car
then the impact is very dangerous as
well so every part of these things is
dangerous
so chuck you'll die 12 ways i was going
to say i'm just dying every way that i
just
asked i guess you didn't outside in
i'm dying on every single level okay all
right good to know good to know
we'll be doing a very efficient job
all right what more do you have okay
um we kind of got to this but um
i think we can get into it maybe a
little deeper because it's a great
question
from whoopsiedoodle on twitter and
whoopsieddildo says hi dr
dr tyson and uh janine i would like to
ask what role does volcanoes play in our
ecosystem and what do they
tell us about the earth we got into the
ecosystem a little bit but
what are we learning about us and this
planet from volcanoes
there's a lot volcanoes can teach us um
like we can
as magma is coming up from very deep
especially hot spot volcanoes which
we have mantle plumes coming up so
that's magma coming up or
at least hot rock coming up from very
very deep below
it can grab chunks of that rock and
bring it up to the surface so we can
actually learn about the insides of our
own planet
that way and without having to dig
without having to dig you'd be taking a
long time
yeah so yeah much more efficient um
they also tell us about how our
atmosphere formed so looking at how our
planet actually evolved
um looking at areas like um geothermal
areas can tell us how life evolved on
this planet and how like things like
extremophiles have actually managed to
survive in these areas
so there's a lot we can learn about our
planet how it's
evolved through time but also how we
have evolved through time
i think we also learn from metals that
come out of volcanoes that harden
in with their magnetic domains aligned
to earth's magnetic field
it tells us that earth's magnetic field
has flipped that was i think the
earliest evidence
of the flipping reverse magnetic field
over the
um over the millennia yeah that can even
help us understand when things erupted
so we can
line those up with different polarities
and understand the ages of eruption
deposits
she really wants to stay employed that's
what it sounds like
[Laughter]
she loves loving
all right this is angry scientists um at
erie edition of life
uh every edition life on twitter says
the light produced by magma and lava
is that red hot glow or brightness
because of photons and does the magma
and lava create their own
photons so it's it's light that we see
coming from it
uh with that yeah is that yeah i can
take this one janine if
if you let me try it yes
i'll let you answer a volcano question
go for it uh yes is
is the answer no it's very simple as you
everything even at room temperature is
emitting infrared
light but your eyes are not sensitive to
that so when you turn out all the lights
you can't see anything
but you take out an infrared camera and
it can see which things are slightly
warmer than
others if you keep raising the
temperature okay
they become more and more visible to the
infrared camera
eventually the glowing object
no longer only emits infrared it'll
begin to emit red light and this is what
happens if you have an electric stove
if you put it on low you don't see it if
you turn out the light put a little
higher begins to glow red
and the temperature at which things glow
red that's up around the thousand
degrees celsius that janine was talking
about
if you want to raise the temperature
some more it'll glow white hot
and i don't think magma gets to white
hot does it janine i don't think it gets
that yellows
you get some yelling okay yeah and so
in transitioning to white hot you go
through a yellow hot phase
um and then the hottest of all hots is
glowing blue hot
and but apparently you're melting these
rocks at red hot so we're good to go
there
yeah you can get burning gases that come
out blue
yeah so that's great and they're for a
different reason not it's not because
they're
thermally glowing blue just because
they're emitting blue lights
specifically
but yeah they're photons they're actual
photons being given and it's no
different from the photons of an
electric stove
that's on high yeah oh i write you a 10
out of 10 for that volcano answer good
job oh well thank you
thank you i get him the honorary
volcanologist right okay um
um this is irene polly
plug-in polly actually from facebook uh
she says greeting doctors
here is what that kind of left me out
here is one question for you guys
how many dormant volcanoes with
potential to cause
now here's the qualifier mass
devastation are there here on earth so
you know that that that excludes a lot
um
what's the definition ginny what's the
definition of dormant
dormance i would say is something that
hasn't erupted
recently but really i don't we don't
really have like a
this is what dormant is this is what
activities okay what does recently mean
to you
is it 10 years 100 years a thousand
years well we call a volcano actively
erupting if something hasn't generally
there are exceptions to this but
generally if it hasn't erupted within
three months so after that three month
markers and we go okay it can be
considered not actively erupting now
but you can still have active systems so
we have a few
crossover terms there but um i think
the important thing there is how
devastating are we talking about
so i see a lot of questions about can we
wipe out life on earth
no um but devastating can be extremely
devastating with a much smaller eruption
if you have a city
on the flank of the volcano oh like
pompeii
for example like pompeii exactly and
there are
some cities living in volcanoes like
kempley flagray right next to pompeii
so but if you're talking about like
impacting a large area
i don't know how many we have um so we
could look at how many we know that have
erupted
those lifestyle eruptions i don't know
either
but that doesn't say that volcanoes that
we know now that
that haven't done that in the past might
not do that in the future
so there have been some volcanoes that
people didn't even really know
of volcanoes before they produced
extremely large eruptions and pinatubo
in the philippines in 1991 was kind of
an example of that was the locals didn't
really see it as a volcano it was just
like a low-lying hill
and then it had the second largest
eruption of the last century
so good question don't know the answer
by the way over uh during pinatubo i had
observing
time allocated for me completing my phd
thesis in chile
in the andes mountains and pinatubo's
ash crossing the pacific ocean
interfered with my observations through
the telescope
the quality the the transmissivity of
the air
of this starlight that's been coming
from the center of the galaxy for 30 000
years
and it's got to slam into pinatubo ash
pissed me off
yeah i was totally in charge of that
thing
that's so funny well there you go um
uh irene uh and by the way irene is
coming from helsinki
finland just wanted to let you know and
she also gave me a
a a friendly little troll by saying
chuck my name is pronounced
irenae so there you go um
the arena yeah helping you out chuck no
no she's she's mocking me
uh neil she's mocking me
her name is irene
oh she's mocking me yeah she's totally
mocking me man oh okay
does that happen a lot what's that does
that happen a lot
chuck is still learning how to read yeah
listen um
i think as a person who has suffered uh
tremendous head trauma all my life that
i do a
fantastic job
reading these names and questions okay
you do you've done great i'm proud of
you okay
we might have time for i think just one
more question chuck oh wow
okay um what do you have okay here we go
here we go here we go
uh this is uh hussain uh
that ain't right uh from
um oh hussein
uh says from twitter if this
ever happened or has this ever happened
and if it does
how much are we prepared for a super
eruption that would a cause
global darkness for months
first of all is that possible that's not
here but
one is that possible two uh
would there be any contingency plans for
something like that
so as far as a volcanic eruption um
there's a lot of
misunderstandings about that so
yellowstone is usually one people refer
to as saying that would destroy the
entire united states but with the
recent very large ones we've seen where
i am in d.c
we'd get about a centimeter or less of
volcanic ash so this wouldn't
cause darkness around the world um
that's not what
blocks out the solar radiation that's
the gases and as
you pointed out those can reduce
visibility
but not cause darkness as far as how
prepared we are
and it's a complicated question because
in volcanology
what we do is we learn as much about
volcanoes as we can to understand what
they've done
and therefore what they might do and
where they might do it
we also put a lot of effort into volcano
monitoring using technology
and building experience to understand
when volcanoes start giving us signals
that hey i might be doing something soon
right because
you're not useful to us unless you can
make an accurate prediction
you need us but we don't we don't do
accurate production
you need us but we're not useful at all
we are very useful excuse me
we give forecasts so just like the
weather who they're not going to say
like it's going to rain over your house
at 3 p.m on friday
i'd be nice if they could yeah come on
meteorologists and my friends be nice
so we say like we might have an eruption
of this this style or this big within
this amount of time
which is incredibly important in this
saves lives now as far as
is society ready
that's not a volcan volcanology question
that it's a political question that's a
community question
and you can look at some of the big
disasters we've had recently even the
pandemic and say
with all the knowledge that we have have
we been prepared
okay well so let me let me uh go out
with this slightly nuanced version of
that question
if you say this could blow
any minute between now and 10 years from
now
and okay that's not very precise but
suppose 10 years go by and it doesn't
blow
do you lose credibility to people who
are trying to make
business decisions on statements that
you make
that's a big problem and generally if
you're going to have unrest
that's that long we're going to the
longer time goes the more information
we're getting we're getting more
information
the more we're monitoring it so we're
gonna understand more what might happen
but you absolutely have volcanoes that
are magma is actually moving towards the
surface and then it slows down and it
stops and then it moves again and then
it stops and this can go on for weeks or
months
so it's really important for us for
people for us to communicate and have
people understand the uncertainty
you know the magma could be racing
towards the surface and if it keeps
going the way it is
it could produce a very large eruption
but that can slow down it can stop
and not all of that magma can erupt so
it's a constantly evolving system
um but yeah so people need to know that
so they can
work along with you when you make your
best guess prediction
based on the data well i'm not going to
say guess what i'm sorry your best
estimate
is forecast yes um and it saves a lot of
lives doing that
and knowing when people need to evacuate
you know that's we don't want people
evacuating and not living in their homes
for weeks and months of the year that's
that's horrible we want to help
people not harm them but getting them
out of the way
in time you know not getting them out of
the way might kill them
so now it's a very difficult area of
helping communities is
when do you evacuate when do you tell
people
like this might happen and we are very
you know we tell people everything and
we know as soon as we know it
as we get more information that updates
constantly just like this pandemic
our information has been changing and
our our estimates of what might happen
has been changing the more data that we
get and that's with any scientific field
and the public of course wants a level
of certainty that rarely the scientist
can ascend to
so well sometimes we can sometimes we
can say this is probably going to erupt
in the next
day or the next hours and it does
there's a lot of different things
um like how well we know that particular
volcano their own hair pool have their
own personality
how well we've been monitoring it to
understand its background level of
activity so what's it normally doing
when it's not erupting
and the more we do that the more we can
understand when things are really
ramping up or when they're changing
all right we got to actually end it
there janine give me one last
words of wisdom in one sentence that we
can take with us and gives us hope
that doesn't start with you need me
volcanoes are an incredibly beautiful
amazing and important part of life on
this planet
so it's up to us to learn how to live
with them and how to keep safe when they
decide to do
what they're going to do beautiful
lovely
love that thanksgiving
[Laughter]
well janine krippner it's great to have
you back on star talk
and for this very important topic and
uh maybe we can uh tap you again for
some more volcanic
wisdom and contribute to the show
chuck always good to have you all right
this has been star talk cosmic queries
neil degrasse tyson here
getting you to keep looking up
you